trying to create this unified land
corridor from Crimea through to donbass
Mario Paul is right is right there in
the middle of it so they've got to
control Mario Polly in order to be able
to say they've got this uninterrupted
land corridor
we're going to see
um all sorts of military hardware as
well as military personnel marching
through Red Square in the next half an
hour or so including we're told as far
as a rehearsal was yesterday with all
some pictures that were leaked from the
rehearsal and there was a 50-ton nuclear
weapon that was paraded along
um
Red Square what
obviously he's trying to flex his
muscles obviously he's trying to say to
the West I do have this military
hardware if I need it would he ever use
it
would he ever use it well again back to
my comments a moment or two ago
everything I thought rationally he would
and wouldn't do actually he's done
differently now I think we hope very
much that he doesn't use a nuclear
weapon but I think we also have to
remember that Russian nuclear Doctrine
agrees with the use of a small tactical
nuclear weapon at a relatively early
stage in a campaign so whereas we've
always crept a a huge Red Line a huge
air gap if you like between Conventional
Weapons and nuclear weapons they have a
much a much narrower air gap okay bear
with me a second
four
[Music]
[Music]
so the defense minister there just
congratulating and welcoming and I'm
guessing among some new recruits as well
[Music]
that's what it looks like
um
but you know
I can't get away from a feeling looking
at these pictures knowing what's going
on as I said a moment or two ago 40 or
50 000 kill wounded Russian soldiers
just what are these what are these
youngsters thinking when they're
standing there they must know what's
going on they must know there's a pretty
awful fate awaiting them and this isn't
just a normal Victory Day Parade when
they can go back to Barracks after this
and have a couple of beers or whatever
I congratulate you on the 77th
anniversary of the victory in the Great
Patriotic War
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I congratulate you on the 77th
anniversary
of the victory in the Great Patriotic
War
[Music]
thank you
I'm guessing they've done it they would
have
um
would just refer to the victory in the
Ukraine war at this stage they certainly
would
um this is very much part of the plan I
mean I don't know what Vladimir Putin
was thinking on the 24th of February
when he ordered the ordered the attack
but all we understand is that he hoped
to be in Kiev and affect regime change
in three or four days so if they're here
for you to achieve that he'd have quite
a lot to be growing about now but he
certainly hasn't achieved that and his
army is now mud in a very bloody
conflict with large numbers of casualism
as I've been saying
what would Victory look like what how
would he how could um Putin save face
well that's a very good question I think
concepts of Victory and defeat really
aren't very relevant here
um this like a lot of modern conflicts
is going to finish with some form of
compromise
um whether it'll be a formal ceasefire
or whether in fact it'll just go into
the deep freeze if you like and stop my
my hunch is that the Russian military
will pretty much have expended
themselves when they've competed
capturing the donbass the donets coming
to Hans provinces
um I don't think they're going to have
much capability to go much further than
that the question then really is how
will the right how will the ukrainians
react
um president zielinski May well say I
wanted one to go back to where they were
on the 24th of February will the
Russians do that no they won't do that
can anybody anybody make them do that
why do they think they can we're not
going to see NATO mount a Iraq style
Coalition operation such as we saw
throwing Saddam Hussein out of Kuwait in
1990 1991 that's just not going to
happen
so the question is will the ukrainians
themselves albeit supported by the
Western are artillery and Equipment
we're giving them will they be strong
enough to throw the Russians out
well they might give it a try but I
think they'll find it really difficult
because ukrainians have done really well
while they've been on the defensive and
the Russians have been losing all their
strength attacking the ukrainians but
when they turn it around and the
ukrainians start getting on the offenses
themselves that's when they'll find
they'll take a huge number of casualties
and I don't believe they'll have the
strength to do it so I think the new
status quo is probably going to be
Ukraine will be 10 15
smaller than it was in the past
taking the opportunity to take the
salute
for the parade parade Minister of
Defense Army General hello
at ease
[Music]
foreign
offices generals and Admirals I
congratulate you
on the day of great victory
the defense of the Netherlands when its
fate was at stake that was always sacred
those feelings of real patriotism
volunteers outside
thank you
it's the same now in these days you're
fighting for our people in donbas for
this security of our motherland Russia
the 9th of May 1945
entered World History forever as a
Triumph of our unified Soviet Union its
unity and spiritual might unprecedented
Feats of heroism at the front end at the
home front the Day of Victory is close
to each of us Hearts there is no family
in Russia which wasn't scored by
scorched by the Great Patriotic War its
memory doesn't fade today
in the ranks of the immortal regiment
grandfather great children and
great-grandchildren of those Warriors
March they carry the photographs of
their forefathers who will stay forever
young and the veterans who are no longer
with us we are proud of the generation
of Victors and that we are the
inheritors and our duties to preserve
the memory of those who defeated Nazism
and to make sure that the horror of a
global war will never be repeated and
that's why despite all the differences
in the international relations Russia
has always been for the creation of the
security of equal and the reliable the
security that's needed by the whole
world community in December last year we
proposed to make a treaty of
non-security guarantees Russia called
for a search for
compromise Solutions
solution but that was in the NATO
countries didn't want to hear us and
this means that in reality they had
quite different plans
and we saw that
they were openly preparing another
punitive operation in danbas so an
aggression against our historical lands
including Crimea
calls in Kiev about the possible
acquisition of nuclear weapons the
nature Alliance began to
move into
their troops into our neighboring
territories and they were creating and
an inacceptable threat to us rights at
our borders everything pointed to the
fact that um a clash with neonesses and
banderavites
the United States and the minions state
was inevitable we saw them unfolding a
military infrastructures
how hundreds of military advisers began
to work and how regular supplies were
being made of weapons the danger grew
every day and the Russia delivered a
preventive strike against the aggressor
that was a forced timely and the only
correct decision the decision of a
sovereign strong and independent country
the United States of America especially
after the collapse of the Soviet Union
began to talk about its explicitivity
and they accumulated but that's not just
the whole world but there are satellites
as well who now have to pretend that
they don't notice anything and swallow
everything patiently but we are a
different country Russia has a different
character we will never give up our love
for our motherland from our faith in our
Traditional Values and to the traditions
of our ancestors
from the respectful peoples and cultures
but in the west they decided to cancel
this value such moral degradation
was based on the cynical
Distortion of the
second world war and the mistreatment of
the memory of the victim the
cancellation of the courage of those who
and this Victory we know that the
American Vector veterans who wanted to
come to the military parade in Moscow
were prohibited from doing that but I
want them to know we are proud of your
feet of heroism and your contributions
to the shared Victory we honor all the
Warriors in the Allied armies the
English the French the Americans the
partisans of China all those who
defeated Nazis militarism esteemed
conrades today the militiamen of the
danbas together with Russian servicemen
are fighting on their land
defeated the enemies were the heroes of
the second of the Great Patriotic War
stood
address our Armed Forces now and the
militiamen of danbas you are fighting
for your motherland for its future so
that nobody will forget the lessons of
the second world war so that there will
be no place in the world for punishers
and Nazis today we bow our heads to the
Blessed memory of those whose lives were
taken by the Great Patriotic War to the
memory of sons daughters fathers mothers
grandfathers husbands wives brothers
sisters relatives and friends
we bow our heads to the memory of the
matters of Odessa who Uber weren't alive
in the Trade union building in May 19
2014 to the memory of women and old
people and children in danbas who died
in the under the shelling of Nazis we
bow our heads to our comrades in arms
who fell in the righteous battle for
Russia
let us observe a minute of Silence
okay
foreign
public organizations will do everything
so care for those families and help them
and a special support will be provided
to the children of the Fallen comrades
in arms and those wounded
I have signed an order to that effect
today I wish the speed recovery to the
wounded soldiers and officers and I
think
doctors and nurses medical personnel in
military hospitals for their courageous
work
I bow my head to you for fighting for
each life very often under the shelling
on the front line without
sparing your own life dear comrades here
now on Red Square
shoulder to shoulders soldiers and
officers are standing here from many
regions of our huge motherland including
those
who
arrived here straight from danbas
directly from the war zone
we remember how Russia's enemy tried to
use against us The Gangs of
international terrorism they try to sow
International and religious enmity to
break us to weaken us from inside but
they failed today are warriors from of
different ethnicities are fighting
together in the battle they Shield each
other from bullets and fragments
entrepnel as as brothers and this is the
strength of Russia the unbeatable
strength of our multi-ethnic nation
today you are defending what our
fathers grandfathers and great fathers
fought for them the highest meaning in
their life were the their motherland's
prosperity and safety and for us their
descendants our loyalty to our
motherland is the greatest value and the
greatest
basis of Russia's Independence those who
defeated Nazism during the Great
Patriotic War showed us an example of
heroism for all times
this is the generation of Victors and we
will always take the example glory to
our glorious Armed Forces for Russia for
victory hooray
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
potential
Battalion by battalion
March
[Music]
it's a distance of one linear
the first Battalion straight one
the others to the right
you're just joining us here at Sky News
for the breakfast show you're witnessing
Victory Day in moscow's Red Square
Russian celebration of the Soviet
Union's role in defeating the German
Nazis in World War II and um as they say
getting their country back Diana magnet
is standing by for is interesting to
hear from President Putin there
um Diana trying to portray NATO as the
aggressor and very much involved in his
words in the punitive operation in
dunbars
yes but to be honest nothing that we
haven't heard from Vladimir Putin before
no Grand announcement simply a
reinforcement to the people of Russia
that what they are doing is in the same
vein as what they're saying I know we've
just got I'm so sorry Diane we've just
got a slight technical issue with
um your audio we'll come back to you in
just a second and instead we'll put that
um to the Lord done it who's with us
here in the studio NATO the aggressor
the Russians are doing everything they
can to try to take heat out of the
situation
yes I mean I think it's fairly
predictable that he would and try and
frame it like that
um to try and get over to his own people
that this isn't a war regression that
the Russians the Putin himself has
launched but actually an important and
necessary defensive operation
to show to the people of Russia that he
is their great leader and he's going to
defend their values going to defend
what's important about about Mother
Russia so therefore to show that the
um the Ukrainian dissidents as he would
like to
to portray them in the donbass in those
two provinces were planning with NATO
support with Western support to
effectively
make an incursion to attack Russia so he
sees the initiative and is attacking the
other way which is how he's really got
to try and dress this up no mention at
all of the failed operation around Kiev
and also no mention as we were saying
earlier would he or would he not take
this as an opportunity to announce a
more General mobilization and the
ramping up of the war he hasn't done
that
as we see the military personnel
marching through Red Square we are going
to see some of the as I said the
military hardware as a show of strength
we won't say aggression but strength
that that's to come shortly but he was
very dismissive of the US and it's he
referred to other countries as part of
the NATO group as millions and
satellites
well again I mean he can portray how he
likes but I mean what he wants to try
and show
um is that it's okay America is the
leader of the West
actually I'm not sure in recent years
how much leadership America has shown in
the west but that's a separate issue but
what he was trying to show is that other
countries written in France Netherlands
whatever just go along with with
whatever we'll be with whatever America
says well we know it's not like that
um
the European Union has its own
structures uh NATO has its own
structures and very much of the members
are
fairly equal in terms of their decision
making certainly in terms of their
ability to agree to things and to veto
things so again he's trying to portray
things as he wants to show them for his
own obvious purposes I'm sure they will
be looking towards Russia in Kiev this
morning Deborah's standing by for us
there hello to you Deborah on more than
one occasion referring to those in
charge particularly referring to
president zelenskio they didn't name him
as neo-nazis
yes and he again didn't he use those
those lies those falsehoods that he used
from the very beginning to try to
justify the invasion of Ukraine
um saying how NATO allies just didn't
want to listen to his compromises
claiming falsely that there was some
kind of plan for an operation to retake
territory in the donbath that had been
held since 2014 by russia-backed
separatists and again that as well like
utterly ludicrous claim that the
government here in Kiev was looking to
acquire nuclear weapons all completely
false all repeated by the Russian
president in his Victory Day speech and
then that language when he addressed the
Russian forces praising them for their
heroism here in Ukraine in this war in
Ukraine saying that they were fighting
the same kind of Justified war that
their forefathers fought during the
second world war against Nazis but what
must that sound like to people here in
Ukraine especially for example around
the regions in Kiev where we've seen
evidence of mass killing of torture of
rape of of Civilian targets being
pummeled by Russian weapons right now in
the east of the country the president
zelensky saying that a school was hit
where 90 civilians were Sheltering in a
bomb shelter 60 of them killed it it it
jars so much with the reality on the
ground it's quite extraordinary and then
when you look at these images it just
shows this and you know this huge
military strength that Russia is Keen to
put on display to the world a military
that frankly fared so badly in the first
phase of this war remember the plan had
been for a lightning strike on kiev for
the government here to be toppled within
days and instead the Russian military
was repelled it's now fighting a
different offensive a recalibrated
offensive in the East and incurring huge
losses and I thought it was interesting
what President Putin said about how he
is going to be ensuring that the
children of the soldiers who have been
killed will be looked after because of
course the war will be impacting so many
families in Russia as well yeah betrayed
himself was President Putin the appeaser
as she said it struck me as well that he
was talking about support for families
of the fallen and those that have
returned to Russia will be taken care of
financially also interesting to hear
your thought Deborah on him continuing
refer to refer to the situation in
Ukraine as a special military operation
yes there had been um speculation hadn't
there that he would use this Victory Day
um speech given that he hasn't got any
great victories to talk about here on
the ground in Ukraine instead to um talk
in Greater uh anxiety about this
fabricated threat that he has accused
Ukraine of posing accusing its
government of being Nazis and use that
as a an excuse to order this General
mobilization of of more Russian forces
to fight an actual war in his words in
Ukraine because of course What's
Happening Here is not described as a war
in Russia but he but there was in the
run-up to today Western officials were
playing down that idea and obviously
they don't know what's going on in his
head but saying they hadn't seen
indications that that would be what
would be announced today and yes so far
that seems to be correct but clearly as
well though very much doubling down down
wasn't he on on his belief that he is
fighting his forces are fighting the
Justified righteous battle the Justified
war in Ukraine which literally couldn't
be further from the truth standing here
in Kiev
thank you uh bringing in in just a
moment uh former British ambassador to
Russia That's Tony Brenton but just as
well we have um well done it with me
here in the studio particularly it's
struck me as we were looking at the
young people smiling as they as they
marched by the young women as they were
marching
um in unison one wonders what might be
going through their minds I think it's a
very good question I mean I think this
whole
Victory Day Parade feels very Hollow to
me I'm sure those watching it in Red
Square are feeling very proud but
looking at we know what what we know
what's going on and it almost looks
fairly ridiculous there I said yes of
course the Russians have got a right to
celebrate the end of the Great Patriotic
War and they lost 27 million people
there's no getting away from that but in
the context of what's going on today
[Music]
this does look faintly ridiculous and as
you say a lot of young people marching
past the shots we saw of women
um all smiling clearly they've been
ordered to smile but what have they
really got to smile about
um other than being told to smile
because that's what they're told to do
um this is
this is more than faintly disquieting
actually
um seeing almost a whole generation of
young military people
be almost abused by their leadership
um I think it's pretty disgraceful
actually
so Tony as I said he's with us um so
Tony I'm not sure if you've ever seen
these events
um in in person of course you you lived
in Moscow previously what are you making
of events today well I mean
a couple of things really and yes I have
attended these events they are one of
the biggest days in the in the in the
Russian annual calendar and um Lord Dan
it may dismiss it as being frankly
ridiculous but in the hearts of the huge
majority of the Russian people it speaks
the truth about how they feel about
their country how they feel about the
west and they're watching Putin whose
speech was a very professional job
um I see no sign at all that he's going
to back away from their reconsidered
aims for the war and now you've had real
problems on the ground as Lord Dennis
said there's no guarantee at all that
they're going to make any faster
military progress than I have already
but the aim of this performance today
has been to underline
um Russian patriotic support for what
their government is doing and we in the
west should be under no Illusions the
Russian public do support what their
government is doing and um you know we
have to factor that in as we consider
where this whole crisis is going
well done it well I know I'm I think um
that point of view is is extraordinary
well extraordinarily well put
um and this is is a complete exercise in
the Russian leadership
um being at one with its people
um and demonstrating to themselves you
asked earlier on who is this all about
well it's very much about the Russian
people themselves to boost their own
self-confidence in their inability
um you know I I refer to it as being
faintly ridiculous it it's it's only
ridiculous in the context of what's
going on in the battlefields in Ukraine
today
um in a general sense of course they've
got every right to to celebrate what
they've done in the past but um we know
how poorly the Russian military has done
and this prompt and Circumstance looks
very professional but when it came to
the mud and the blood in um
in in Ukraine they were found wanting
but Tony um there is conscription of
course isn't that
sure what
that is and
and scripted for about a year is it yes
they are um I don't know what age it is
but one of the rumors put about before
this today was actually that Putin would
announce that Russia is now at war with
Ukraine and um therefore conscription
could start he's plenty decided not to
do that for good reasons firstly it will
be a statement of failure Lord Danish is
absolutely right about the failure of
the Russian troops so far in Ukraine to
achieve their objectives there'll be a
statement of failure that he has to
raise the level of military involvement
and actually conscription takes time you
have to train the people and so on so it
would not make any immediate difference
on the ground to the Russian performance
so Tony what did you make of the speech
and the demeanor of President Putin this
morning
I I was impressed is the wrong word I've
dealt with him close too he's a very
professional closed personality you
can't tell ever really what he's
thinking but he has shown disturbing
signs over the last few weeks of kind of
losing it he certainly didn't today he
was very professional performance it
pushed all the right patriotic buttons
in in the Russian political
atmosphere his allusions to the history
dismissed I think by your correspondent
but actually the Russians really believe
that expanding NATO over the past 20
years which is what has happened is a
real threat to their security and he
dwelt on that the Russians really
believe that there's a a neo-fascist
danger in Ukraine and Putin referred
twice I think to a man called Bandera
who actually LED Western Ukraine in
support of the German invasion back in
the war so Putin pushed all the right
buttons he's um he did it in a coherent
way which he hasn't always recently and
in a way it's slightly encouraging I
mean I have no sympathy at all for the
message in any of that but it is rather
encouraging that it it leaves and leaves
me with a feeling that we are dealing
with a rational individual there with
whom hopefully in time it will be
possible to do a sensible deal to bring
this whole mess to an end
well I would like to think we are
dealing with a rational individual
um I go back to where we were in in
February it did not seem the rational
thing to do to launch the attack that he
did on the 24th of February up to that
point by having a large force on the
Ukrainian border intimidating bullying
posturing all the Western leaders Peter
Parker is all they wanted to come and
talk to him it's a rational thing to do
would have been to have maintained that
degree of pressure but not to have not
to have attacked in the way that he did
he did the attack failed and we are we
are where we are yeah I agree
agree and Charlie that the attackers one
second Mr Tony I'll come back to you in
just a second just make his point this
issue of rationality is really important
when we put it in the nuclear context
because
the Cold War and the nuclear standoff
during the Cold War worked because both
sides were rational both sides
understood the catastrophic consequences
of the use of nuclear weapons so they
didn't do it so for us to believe that
Putin is still rational and I'm very
pleased that it's Tony Brenton said that
he felt that his analysis of this
morning shows a degree of rationality
that's encouraging
um it's the irrationality the potential
craziness of Putin that is the real
worry particularly if he's not well now
he looked pretty healthy to me this
morning but there is the issue of of
what is the underlying state of his
health yeah so Tony sorry
yeah
um I mean I very much agree with what
Lord says there um the the launching of
the attack was a huge blunder although I
do recall that at the time the um the
chairman of the US Joint Chiefs said
that he rather expected the Russians to
be in cave in 72 hours so it wasn't only
the Russians who miscalculated the the
likely effectiveness of the attack
um it has turned out to be a huge
blunder and I'm pretty sure that Putin
and the people around him will be
looking for how can I put it a
respectable way out
um which it would which and as I've said
as I think lordanes has agreed we can
hope that they are going to behave
rationally in looking for that uh I
don't think in any case that Putin ever
had any intention of getting into a
nuclear confrontation with NATO both
Russia and NATO have worked very hard at
leaving the conflict as one between
Ukraine and Russia although everyone is
helping Ukraine a lot and I don't think
as I say that Russia wants to get into a
real fight with NATO but I wouldn't rule
out if the Russians really begin to have
to retreat and lose in Ukraine and in
particular if there's a threat to their
control of Crimea that they would be
willing to use tactical nuclear weapons
there
well done it well you're saying earlier
on that within Soviet and our Russian
military Doctrine their the potential to
use small tactical nuclear weapons is
very much there they don't see it as the
huge escalation that we would we would
regard it in in the west I hope that
doesn't happen because once you've
crossed the nuclear threshold in any
shape or form
the fear is that the escalation up the
ladder or down the ladder will be will
be horrifically rapid so I think we have
to really hope that a way is found
through this
for both sides Russia and Ukraine to
find some way out of this with a degree
of dignity that doesn't involve what
would now seem to ask to be an
irrational and certainly unwise and very
damaging decision to use a nuclear
weapon however smaller one um
so Tony I've been reading a little bit
about tactical nuclear weaponry and the
conclusion seems to be from most that um
that that's the misnomer you either use
nuclear weapons with the Fallout that
that results in or you don't
yeah and that's right and lordana it is
absolutely right
um even if they use nuclear weapons in
Ukraine alone and make it very clear
that they don't want to get into a
confrontation with NATO at the nuclear
level that is the breach of a 70 year
old avoidance by everybody on the use of
nuclear weapons it transforms an awful
lot of global politics people like the
Iranians the Egyptians the Saudis would
suddenly all also want nuclear weapons
and we're all suddenly living in a much
more dangerous world so Lord than it is
also absolutely right that we need to
find a way to put away from that threat
now John F Kennedy at the time of the um
the Cuba Missile Crisis said when you're
confronted with a nuclear armed
adversary you do not back them into a
total corner you always find a way out
for you I think it's rather important
that we in the west and not all Western
politicians are acknowledging this we in
the west not only leave open but
actually look for ways of dignified way
out for Russia the alternatives are
really too dangerous to contemplate
[Music]
I think that's right and it's not just a
dignify way out for Russia it's
dignified way out for Ukraine
um very interesting that President
zielinski the other day was talking
about reverting to positions uh
which were on the ground on the 24th of
February he didn't as far as I'm aware
make any reference about returning
Crimea to Ukraine
it comes back to the point we were
discussing 20 or 30 minutes ago okay
when this war stabilizes and the
Russians have effectively shot their
balls and used up their remaining combat
power and have got control of that land
Corridor through the donbass I've got
control of the donbass itself
um what what are they going to do then
that's probably where this thing will go
into the deep freeze
and it's well and good for
um our foreign secretary Liz Liz trust
to talk about
every last Russian soldier has got to be
excluded from from Ukraine and by
implications she was talking about
Crimea as I said earlier that is just
not going to happen the Russians are not
going to withdraw voluntarily
um we might put all the economic
sanctions in the world that we like on
them but even that's not going to create
enough pressure for the Russians to
withdraw from the land that they've
captured
the ukrainians will never be able to
throw them out so the ukrainians are
probably going to have to accept a new
status quo now the difficulty for the
West is we have been supporting Ukraine
and we are supporting Ukraine very
vigorously at the present moment
but if there comes a point when Western
politicians have to start saying to
zielinski you may have to accept the
part of your country is under permanent
the Russian occupation
we the West are going to be portrayed by
the ukrainians so having sold them down
the line so there's a lot of different
different agendas that have got to be
identified and managed here and we'll
take that up with Deborah who's in Kiev
in just a second but just to um let you
know what's happening um here as you're
just joining us uh on Sky News on the
breakfast show this morning this is the
Russian celebration of the Soviet
Union's role in defeating the German
Nazis in World War II
um and we have seen the parade of the
military personnel now comes the
hardware and one item perhaps to watch
out for is a giant intercontinental
ballistic missile it's weighs apparently
about 50 tons and is able to carry up to
10 Warheads we know that it's uh
probably going to be paraded because it
certainly was in the rehearsals that the
Kremlin had in Red Square yesterday it's
got a range we're a total of seven and a
half thousand miles it's a thermo at
nuclear warhead and it's capable we're
told of striking London or New York in a
matter of minutes one wonders at what
message President Putin would like us to
take from that we will illustrate it
when we will certainly pointed out to
when we see it come through Red Square
in the meantime let's bring in Deborah
and uh your thoughts to what Lord was
just telling us there Deborah about the
fact that the ukrainians at some stage
will be left to their own devices rather
like what happened with Afghanistan back
in August and then comes the retribution
yeah just first I just wanted to just
mention you've obviously got this
display of Hardware
um on the screens these Russian tanks
clearly not in as great a number as
normal given that so much military
equipment was sent over here to Ukraine
and just outside the town of butcher
there is um a Russian tanks graveyard
where you have a heap of Russian Twisted
Russian vehicles that have been
um destroyed by Ukraine's military
Ukraine is very keen to let people know
just how many Russian tanks armored
vehicles pieces of artillery they've
managed to destroy in large part thanks
to Western weapons which has been this
curious situation where you have the
West not wanting to put boots on the
ground in Ukraine but very much wanting
to make sure the ukrainians have the
right equipment to be able I mean let's
not beat around the butt here to be able
to kill Russian soldiers which is what
they're doing so you have many Russian
troops being killed by Western weapons
and a lot of Russian Hardware being
destroyed but clearly Russia still has
plenty of military equipment to be able
to show on display and you also see as
well pictures faces of some of the
Russian military personnel who have been
killed here in Ukraine and also being
remembered as part of this Victory Day
parade and just in terms of what lordana
was saying about what might play out
here in Ukraine I do disagree that the
idea that the West will will loosen its
support for this country they do realize
finally belatedly that this right now is
a fundamental Battle of values they
failed to realize that Western allies I
mean including the UK back in 2014 when
Russia first broke the rules of the game
completely violated International Norms
by invading Ukraine in the first place
and annexing Crimea the response from
the West to that was weak it meant that
Putin was then able to continue with his
malign operations just calling them what
they are in terms of for example the
poisoning of
um using novotok of surrogated repellent
his daughter in in Salisbury and then
again feeling that he had he could act
with impunity launching this Invasion a
second time on the 24th of February in
the face of all those warnings from the
West about the consequences that he
would face should he choose to cross
that line and attack Ukraine with a
full-scale Invasion he did that anyway
and you really feel a NATO now that's
galvanized that realizes that their
freedoms are under threat too and that's
why I mean President Putin in his speech
did talk about
um he kind of turned it around didn't he
talked about how NATO has mobilized
troops closer to Russia's border and he
kind of tried to suggest that that was a
reason for him launching The Invasion
the reality of course is that Russia was
threatening to launch this invasion of
Ukraine without saying it overtly but
had masked more than a hundred thousand
troops around Ukraine's borders for
months and in response to that trying to
deter Russia from taking that step NATO
allies then mobilized and sent thousands
of additional forces towards their
borders with Russia trying to hope that
they could make President Putin think
twice he didn't and that's why you are
in this situation where if Ukraine is
not supported if Russia is successful in
this country then NATO allies that
border most closely to this region we're
talking about the Baltic states and
Poland in particular really
fundamentally believed that they could
then be next and they believe that
um that Putin's ultimate gain is to push
back the clock and and regain the Soviet
Union Prestige that Russia was once at
the heart of and so that is why I I
disagree that it will be you know that
this will fade the support for Ukraine
will fade and the big question though is
how this can possibly end president
zielinski this week said that at a
starting point for negotiations Russia
needs to roll back to the lines that
were drawn up uh before the 24th of
February so that means taking his forces
out of Ukraine completely apart from
where in the donbass region you've had
russia-backed separatists and that line
of contact that's been there for the
last eight years
um so Tony is the um the show of
military strength rumbles on through Red
Square I did catch a glimpse of um a
shot of President Putin and he we talked
about how he looked quite well today but
I noticed that he um has quite a heavy
blanket covering um covering his knees
um as opposed to some of the others sat
around him but he's going to be pretty
pleased about what people can see today
yeah I the heavy blanket is an
interesting detail there have been
regular rumors of ill health in Putin
which of course have not been
acknowledged by the Kremlin but he has
been locked away as a result of coving
for the last two years and is only now
as a result of the war having having to
re-engage those people who have spoken
to him people like macron and the
Americans have reported back less
coherence than they are used to getting
from him so there are reasons to be
worried about you but we need to be a
little bit careful about what we wish
for if he fell under a bus if he is
genuinely ill there is no reason at all
particularly in present circumstances to
imagine that whoever replaces him would
be in any way preferable from our point
of view
Well Done It This is a big year now
isn't it
it looks like it yeah
um I mean we've seen much more Convent
all the Conventional Weapons coming past
but um this is I think is where he's
trying to make the point that um yes
they have a full Suite of capability
including nuclear capability well we
know that
um but clearly it's important to him
it's important to him to show to the
Russian people that they have got this
equipment
and it's being paraded they've been
stuck under our noses if you like
um
on your thoughts on what um Deborah was
talking about when it comes to Ukraine
next steps what happens as far as the
West is concerned Well the West will
continue to support our Ukraine
um but I think the point that we've got
to try and over time work out is
how what is that support going to look
like what is what are we going to what
are we trying to help the ukrainians
actually achieve come back to the point
that I've made a couple of times I can't
see anybody ukrainians or NATO having
the will or the means to throw the
Russians out and I can't see the
Russians leaving voluntarily so it is a
fact of the future that when the this
active phase of War stops the Russians
will be in control of this land Corridor
they will be control of much of the
donbass area and they will retain that
control now are we going to go on
supporting the ukrainians fighting some
kind of gorilla
um
I got some kind of a gorilla fight
against the um against the Russians are
we going to agree that they should carry
on sporadic shelling and launching minor
sort of counter-offensive and whatever
and this on that basis this walker go on
for a very very long time
um
and it's very difficult to see what the
solution is going to be
um
my my concern is what I was trying to
voice before is that the West may feel
the right thing to do is persuade the
ukrainians to accept that they have lost
part of their territory and try and come
to terms with that and allow their
country to move forward because after a
tremendous amount of Ukraine has been
destroyed and it's got to be rebuilt but
what is the point of rebuilding some of
their bordering cities and towns if they
remain within artillery range of the
Russians and could be destroyed again so
there's got to be some kind of decision
point of when this thing stops and a new
status quo is recognized what we hope
very much that the ukrainians will
arrive at that conclusion themselves and
it won't be Western pressure that puts
them there because if it's Western
pressure that puts them there they can
actually then say the ukrainians can say
the West has sold them out and we don't
want that to happen
just listening again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
about to lay a wreath at the Tomb of the
Unknown Soldier
it's nine o'clock you're watching Sky
News and continuing coverage of the
Russian celebration of the Soviet
Union's role in defeating the German
Nazis in World War II known as Victory
Day in Moscow it was an occasional event
since the end of the second World War
until the president Royce Yeltsin for
the 50th Anniversary reinstated the
event as an annual occasion
my Lord I enjoyed
I was really just commenting on them how
President Putin looked
um he doesn't seem to be moving as
freely and as easily as one has seen him
do in the past and I think we've all
commented it actually looked pretty
puffy around the face I don't know how
well or how unwell he is
um as Tony Brent said there's some quite
well circulating frequently circulating
rumors that he's got cancer of some sort
um I don't know
um
and again as Tony Branson said if he
goes under a bus metaphorically or
realistically
um will the um replacement be actually
anymore
will any better any more any more
meaningful to the West
um these are all big questions big open
questions
um and I think
going back to sort of January February
we rather hope we were all hoping that
booting wouldn't attack this wouldn't be
the kremlin's war that the Russian
people would not agree with it but I
think what we're actually seeing is this
the control of the state media as such
and his message today was so strong and
so well argued that actually probably
the majority of Russian people do think
that he is a good leader that he is
doing the right thing by their country
so it does not follow that if he goes
under a bus for whatever reason
metaphorically that another leader will
be any more meaningful to the West I'm
pleased to say that Diana is is now back
with us we've sorted out the Gremlins um
Diana
um your take on what we've seen over the
past hour
well I think in the absence of being
able to deter any kind of actual Victory
this was really the best that Vladimir
Putin could give and I'm pretty much in
line what you would expect trying to
equate uh what is happening now in
Ukraine with the sort of Victories of
the people's Soviet forebears at the end
of what Russia calls the Great Patriotic
War and he repeated themes that he's
used in speeches before that this is not
our fault it's all the West's fault this
is NATO's fault we tried to establish a
new security treaty but the West NATO
had other plans
emphasizing Russian exceptionalism
emphasizing that this was all about
defending the motherland and that they
had to do a preemptive strike to protect
themselves I mean all of this we've
heard from him before it's what's
repeated on state TV constantly and as
we were just hearing from the guest
before me a lot of people in this
country believe it I mean talked to a
lot of people there are still many who
use vpns who read different news but the
vast majority don't I think there is an
unease about what's going on but there's
also a duality in a way in in the
Russian people's minds that
um Victory Day is a big holiday a cause
to celebrate the horrific losses that
their fathers and grandfathers sustained
in World War II and that it's really
somehow separate from what is going on
in Ukraine
um so it is possible that he can make
all sorts of announcements in the coming
days but for today this was really about
the Quest for victory the fact that none
of this is Russia's fault that um what
he's doing he's doing for the for the
motherland
um and and and and it is a message that
resonates because the more you hear this
kind of thing on your television box in
every speech whether it's from Vladimir
Putin or whether it's from Sergey lavrov
or whether it's from Dmitry peskov or
whether it's from any number of
propagandists on every every single
state TV channel in all of the talk
shows which really are a kind of
resounding chorus of the drum beats of
war and pundits saying everything that
points to Western aggression and uh
points to sort of Russian saintlyness
then at the end of the day you're going
to believe it and I think we see this in
the Russian public in the fact that they
do think that Ukraine is a wash with
Nazis and they're doing their very best
to rid the the the the the world of this
Scourge
um because that is the kind of rhetoric
and language that Vladimir Putin has
used consistently there were all these
questions about whether he would use
this as an opportunity to declare a
broader war against NATO but I think
that is always the backdrop of how he's
pitched this anyway that Russia is
trying to defend itself against an
aggressive West who is out to undermine
and Destroy Russia
um the fact that for the West this
really isn't about Russia at all but
about Ukraine and trying to defend its
sovereignty isn't really a message that
at Hammer's home here
so Tony how would you measure the tone
of today compared to previous Victory
Parade days that you have perhaps
attended
well the important difference I mean the
victory parades that I attended were
happened in a time of Peace where Russia
had had Robin relations or actually on
that one put stage had really had rather
good relations with the west and
therefore the celebration of Russia's
victory in the in the second world war
was just that a historic celebration and
a celebration of of Russia's strength it
has turned into on this occasion
yes a celebration of Russia's strength
but a reaffirmation of Russia's
determination to achieve its objectives
in Ukraine unfortunately
um and I think as I said it's a useful
reminder to us in the west that badly as
they've been doing on the battlefield
and rottenly as we think they're
governed and
economically the the threats that are
open to them is a lot of our sanctions
nevertheless we are dealing with a
formidable country really quite United
politically populated very largely by by
Patriots
who are at the moment determined to
carry on with their operation and we
need to find a way of persuading them or
finding a place where they can stop
and Lord Donald was talking earlier
about maybe combined Western pressure on
on Ukraine I think that's very unlikely
to happen for obvious reasons it's just
not sellable politically in London apart
from anywhere else I think as Lord
Dennett also says we're likely to the
war will end when the Russians achieve
their objectives and when the ukrainians
recognize that they're not going to be
able to push the Russians out of the Don
bass and the chess on other places we're
not there yet it's going to go on for a
while but when we do reach that point
there needs to be a concerted effort
which we in the UK should support and
that's not guaranteed because we have
among the most hawkish politicians on
this issue on the planet but there will
be at that point there will need to be
an effort to get the two countries back
around the negotiating table and I very
much hope that by then we in the UK will
will be will be on message for that uh
Deborah Withers in Kiev as well of
course
um as we see President Putin walking uh
through gold through Red Square I should
say and we believe towards the Tomb of
the Unknown Soldier in order to lay a
wreath there on this Victory Parade day
in Moscow and um Deborah he's I think
that's the defense minister isn't it
that is
um the head of the defense Ministry yeah
that he is walking with towards the Tomb
of the Unknown Soldier one wonders
um how angry and private if not in
public he is with some of his generals
and the way that they have conducted
this campaign
yeah so it'll be interesting what people
make of his of the body language between
the two of them and there have been a
lot of speculation that Sergey shoigu
his defense his long-standing defense
minister
um might have to uh be chucked under a
bus to pay the price for how badly the
operation the war in Ukraine has gone so
far you'll remember he kind of
disappeared from view didn't he for the
first couple of weeks and there was all
sorts of speculation as to what might or
might not have happened to him and then
he re-emerged
um to in front of the cameras speaking
to President Putin last month when um
they announced they sort of declared
that they had liberated in their words
the Strategic city of mariopol obviously
it's not been completely put under
Russian control because there is still
that stronghold of resistance at the
steel Works
um but yes the two men walking as usual
together oh sorry
let's just uh pause for a moment as
President Putin takes the opportunity to
lay a wreath at the Tomb of the Unknown
Soldier in Moscow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's reasonable to say that
even if one doesn't agree with the
conflict one almost there's Fallen
Soldiers
yes it's a very solemn an important
moment
come back to the original purpose of
this Victory Day Parade 27 million
Russians lost their lives in the Great
Patriotic War
um and he had known Graves many had
unknown groups so it's only right and
proper that their leader does lead a
moment of respect at the Tomb of the
Unknown Warrior we do the same in in
this country you can't you can't change
history 27 million Russians lost their
lives
the awkwardness of today is the way it
conflates and overlays on what is going
on in Ukraine which we have a very clear
view in the west of that not being the
right thing to do
Putin leading the Russian people to
believe it's a necessary thing to do
there we have a disagreement of Minds on
this one
um and that's why today today's whole
ceremony in many ways feels awkward
understandable from historical sense
understandable which I'm trying to
I think the Russian people feel good
about their capability good about their
leadership but we I think actually
understand the truth of what is
happening in Ukraine rather more than
the average Russian does this is deeply
uncomfortable as well it's a it's a it's
a conflation of emotions that is in
Moscow Diner do you agree with the
feeling of awkwardness today
absolutely but actually
um I think that Vladimir Putin almost
could have gone heavier than he did I
mean this was you know we didn't have
the airplane flyover that we normally do
that's normally canceled because of bad
weather
um and rain was forecast today so that's
probably why it was canceled
um he didn't make any Grand
announcements and and first and foremost
this day is a incredibly patriotic
moment in the Russian calendar precisely
because of the horrific loss of life 27
million lives lost during what Russians
call the great Great Patriotic War and
that loss and that memory Vladimir Putin
has really built up into almost a sort
of cult status throughout his time in
office for the last 22 years for example
in a few hours time we'll have the march
of the immortal regiment where people go
out with placards of their grandfathers
and fathers who served in World War II
and remember that them that really has
only gained currency over the last
decade or so it was a Grassroots
initiative essentially to a large extent
hijacked by Vladimir Putin and and sort
of used to Corral a patriotic further
and that patriotic further he has used
to support what it is that he has
decided to do in Ukraine and he's
painted the reasons for that uh very
much in the colors of the Great
Patriotic War which now is something
that people understand if you go to any
village town city in this huge country
you will see people celebrating today
you will see little children dressed up
in sort of uh uniforms from the second
world war you'll see them all playing in
tanks this is a very militarized Society
where the memory of World War II sits
very very deep and so of course you can
capture the people's imagination by
painting what is happening in Ukraine in
the same light what I would also say is
that on these key patriotic moments like
defender of the father and day February
the 23rd that was also a moment where
Vladimir Putin honored the past the
veterans the great
um a victory in World War II and the
very next day he declared this special
military operation in in Ukraine tried
to take care of that clearly failed
um so just because he stood there today
and said what he said before I.E this is
all the West's fault it's not ours we're
doing what we can and must to defend our
motherland doesn't mean that he won't
make any other announcements any other
time there's been all this speculation
about possible mobilization
um and I think you know we have no idea
whether that really is true or not but a
lot of people here are talking about it
a lot of people here are worried about
it we were just in the city of
yucatarinburg and people are definitely
you know young men and definitely
talking about it and some of them would
be prepared to go and fight feeling that
it is their patriotic Duty and a lot a
lot of others who we spoke to and the
young you know aren't quite so sold on
this whole thing uh aren't quite so sure
that that would really be such a great
thing and especially as um as you know
these weeks and months unfold more and
more people are hearing of soldiers that
they might know from their Village or
from their Town who've gone uh to
donbass and died and was it all really
worth it we'll have to see whether you
know depending on how long that this
goes on for whether that changes the
tide of public opinion because it
certainly did in Afghanistan which
dragged on for
um a decade essentially certainly did
also in chechnya where there were huge
losses for Russia but remember that we
are essentially in a in a zone of
military censorship here where you can't
say anything that discredits the Armed
Forces because you'll be prosecuted
where you can't even call this a war
um you know so so it's very easy when
you're not able to really um speak out
against what's happening to just fall in
with it because actually what else can
you do and what else can you do Beyond
um assuming the sort of patriotic
position because there's literally so
little you can do
to take a stand against this if you if
you don't believe
um the rhetoric that the Russian
government uses about it
well within the last few moments we have
seen President Putin laying a wreath at
the Tomb of the Unknown Soldier at the
same time the UK defense secretary has
been speaking he says the conflicts in
Ukraine dishonors Russian soldiers past
and present uh if you were not with us
in the last hour you would not have
heard what President Putin had to say on
this Victory Parade day in Moscow so
let's uh pause to have another lesson
in these days you're fighting for our
people in dunbars for this security of
our motherland Russia
the 9th of May 1945
entered World History forever as a
Triumph of our unified Soviet Union its
unity and spiritual might
unprecedented
Feats of heroism at the front and at the
home front
Day of Victory is close to each of us
Hearts there is no family in Russia
which wasn't scored by scorched by the
Great Patriotic War its memory doesn't
fade today
in the ranks of the immortal regiment
grandfather great children and
great-grandchildren of those Warriors
March they carry the photographs of
their
forefathers who will stay forever young
and the veterans who are no longer with
us we are proud of the generation of
Victors and that we are the inheritors
and our duty is to preserve the memory
of those who defeated Nazism
has to be alert and to make sure that
the horror of a global war will never be
repeated and that's why despite all the
differences in the international
relations Russia has always been for the
creation of the security of equal and
the reliable the security that's needed
by the whole world community in December
last year we proposed to make the Treaty
of non-security guarantees Russia called
for a search for
compromise social
but that was in vain NATO countries
didn't want to hear us and this means
that in reality they had quite different
plans and we saw that
they were openly preparing another
punitive operation in danbas so an
aggression against our historical lands
including Crimea
calls in Kiev about the possible
acquisition of nuclear weapons the NATO
alliance began to
move into it absolutely their troops
into our neighboring territories and
they were creating and an inacceptable
threat to us rights at our borders
everything pointed to the fact that
clash with neonatres and banderavites
United States and the minions States was
inevitable we saw them unfolding a
military infrastructures
however hundreds of military advisors
has began to work and how regular
supplies were being made of weapons the
danger grew every day and the Russia
delivered a preventive strike against
the aggressor that was a forced timely
and the only correct decision the
decision of a sovereign strong and
independent country
address our Armed Forces now and the
militiamen of danbas you are fighting
for your motherland for its future so
that nobody will forget the lessons of
the second world war so that there will
be no place in the world for punishers
and Nazis today we bow our heads to the
Blessed memory of those whose lives were
taken by the Great Patriotic War to the
memory of Sons daughters fathers mothers
grandfathers husbands wives brothers
sisters
relatives and friends
we bow our heads to the memory of the
matters of Odessa who were burnt alive
in the Trade union building in May 19
2014 to the memory of women and old
people and children in danbas who died
in the under the shelling of Nazis we
bow our heads to our comrades in arms
in the righteous battle for Russia
so the um Victory Parade Victory Day
continues in Moscow as we speak watching
events with us was Ivana Clem push
sidsadi who's chair of the Parliamentary
committee on integration of Ukraine to
the EU and also a member of Ukraine's
Parliament and former deputy prime
minister of Ukraine as well thank you so
much for taking the time to join us this
morning your thoughts on what you've
been witnessing this morning
well thank you for having me let me
correct a couple of things that have
been sounding during your reporting this
morning you've been uh saying that 27
millions of Russians have died in the
second world war which is uh nonsense uh
up to 10 million those were ukrainians
and there were millions of other nations
and that is part of the Soviet
propaganda that claims that those were
Russians that have fought in the second
uh World War that's one thing with
regard to uh uh with I'm sorry I can
hear the the Russian language here and I
cannot talk okay it's better now well
with regard to what I saw this is yet
another manipulation by Putin trying to
justify its War by pretending that it
was there was some threat from NATO
countries and from Ukraine to the
Russian Federation while our only guilt
in this war is that we wanted to develop
our Sovereign independent country and
country that would pursue European and
your authentic integration path and that
is something that Russia disagrees with
and Russia wants to erase us from the
map of the world that's the goal uh the
the most
um closest kind of tactical goal of
Russian Federation in this in this war
that has been already
um also pronounced by
um Minister lavrov as well as
geopolitical goal of Russian Federation
in this war and another thing that is
very important to remember that
um Russia is not going to stop and by
this parade and by by this uh speech
that is another
um attempts to mobilize the Russian
society and we have to understand that
there is no Putin's war against Ukraine
there is a collective responsibility of
Russian Federation and Russian people
who are supporting this bloody barbaric
war of addressing totally
um unjustified and totally without any
uh without any provocation coming to our
land and one more thing there was also
some some expert that just said on your
uh on air here that um once ukrainians
will recognize that we could that they
cannot regain their territories we you
would have to make us sit down at the
table with Russian Federation I want to
um for you to understand everybody to
understand our only
um chance to survive as a nation as a
country as an independent sovereign
state is to fight back and to ensure
that Russians are kicked out from our
motherland and we would expect the Free
World to stand by and uh to stand behind
us and to reinforce us with all the
possible instruments in order for us to
be able